[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce 7,8 sport
l'émission est consacrée comme vous le
savez à l'actualité sportive dans le
département c'est parti pour le sommaire
handball ce lundi plaisir est toujours
dans le top 3 de nationale 3 mais les
plaisirs ont connu leur première défaite
en 2018 et se sont inclinés à 28 à 27 à
l'extérieur contre massy ce week-end le
résumé du match et a su dans quelques
instants
cyclisme la sélection française pour les
championnats du monde sur piste a été
dévoilée au vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et ed affiche
française françois pervis sébastien vie
j'aime at il de gros ont été retenus
pour ce rendez vous les détails dans ce
magazine découverte coup de projecteur
aujourd'hui sur le floorball une un
sport collectif qui rassemble aux qui
ressemble au hockey sur glace sans les
patins et son contact violent une
compétition est organisée ce week-end
dans les yvelines un coup de projecteur
à présent sur les principaux résultats
du week-end dans le département
[Musique]
mais avant de développer ses titres
retour sur les intempéries qui ont
perturbé les championnats de football et
de rugby ce week end en r4 les
footballeurs de trappes n'ont pas pu se
déplacer sur le terrain d'ozoir ce
dimanche les trappistes n'ont plus joué
en championnat depuis à la mi-décembre
en nationale 3 verset n'a pas pu
recevoir bobigny à domicile le match est
reporté pour la deuxième fois de la
saison sur les terrains de rugby versa
qui devait recevoir le leader sarcelles
le sky rugby monti le bretonneux chevaux
et plaisir n'ont pas joué à ce week end
tous les matches sont reportés il
pourrait être rejoué pendant les
vacances de février
en football américain à matches reportés
également pour les templiers d'elancourt
les élans courtois devait affronter ce
samedi soir les spartiates d'amiens au
complexe sportif europe pour le compte
de la 3e journée du championnat de 2e
division la rencontre et décalée à une
date ultérieure on les écoute le
directeur sportif des templiers
d'elancourt frederick henderson
les joueurs étaient était naturellement
déçu parce que pour eux il a déjoué ce
week-end et c'est vrai que le fait qu'il
n'y ait pas de matches pas toute cette
préparation et toute cette anticipation
bas s'effondre il va falloir attendre un
petit peu avant de jouer le prochain
match mais d'un autre côté ça laisse un
peu plus de temps pour pour se préparer
continué de progresser donc c'est aussi
pour un mal pour un bien on apprend
aussi à la faire avec les aléas de la
météo
prochain match pour les templiers
d'elancourt le samedi 24 février à
domicile contre les pionners appuyé au
nlhe et de touraine malgré le report de
plusieurs rencontres les matchs en
intérieur on était a maintenu handball
plaisir deuxième se déplacer sur le
terrain de massy à troisième ce dimanche
pour le choc de cette 12e journée du
championnat de nationale 3 le match
s'est soldé par une victoire des
essonniens 28 à 27 dans les dernières
secondes
le résumé du match les images sont
signés à nicolas landry lille défaite
rageante pour les jaune et noir de
plaisir après avoir mené pendant une
grande partie du match à l'extérieur les
ivy loix 2e de national troyes n'ont pas
réussi à conserver leur avantage et
s'incline contre leurs poursuivants
classement massy score final 28 à 27 ans
selon dessus parce que
je pense qu'on avait toutes les armes
pour gagner le match
ils ont joué au métier dont ils n'ont
pas paniqué quand il était à moins 4 ils
sont revenus petit à petit au score et
et nous on a acheté des ballons un peu
trop vêtements là où on aura dû attendre
un peu plus travailler un peu plus
autour de leur défense on fait une
entame de match
irréprochable et derrière on donne
beaucoup beaucoup trop de ballons à
l'adversaire
un retournement de situation orchestrée
par le gardien de massy justin porte à
l'homme clé de cette rencontre a mis en
échec les plaisirs ou en réalisant une
quinzaine d'arrêt pendant la partie se
féliciter de sa partie est
j'irai pas dans le registre de dire que
le gardien n'est pas bon bien au
contraire
maintenant
il faut être parfois capable de savoir
lire les modes de jeu des joueurs
adverses et dans ce registre là on a été
très mauvais on attirait toujours dans
le même mode de jeu et le gardien a fait
toutes ses parades dans les mêmes
intentions donc c'est assez frustrant
au classement ce résultat permet à massy
de revenir à hauteur des plaisirs à la
deuxième place du championnat avec 28
points chacun une défaite qui pourrait
remettre en cause les espoirs de montée
du promu évinois maintenant on a attendu
je pense qu'on était un peu la surprise
du des matches aller de phase aller je
pense que c'est pas pour rien aussi que
moi si nous aligner quelques quelques
bons joueurs
ce que voilà maintenant il n'y a plus
l'effet de surprise donc on va être
attendu un peu partout à nous de faire
en sorte d'élever notre niveau de jeu
les plaisirs roy devront élever leur
niveau de jeu dès leur prochain match
ils recevront le dimanche 4 mars le
leader saint polois cette fois-ci
défaite interdite pour ce choc
en basket ont joué ce week-end pour le
compte de la 15e journée de nationale 3
trappe s'est lourdement incliné à
domicile contre saint thomas basket le
havre score final à 88 à 60 4
au classement les trappistes descendent
à la cinquième place du championnat mais
reste à un petit point du podium on
écoute les réactions à la fin de la
rencontre
je pense qu'on a fait une bonne première
mi-temps et en deuxième mi-temps on
explose donc d'un manque d'envié et de
concentration manque de respect des
consignes donc là on va s'atteler à
revenir à lundi à de s'entraîner et à
comprendre pourtant on a perdu c'est
qu'on des quêtes contre des cadets qu'on
a joué donc c'est inadmissible en plus
avec le score on perd 2,20 points c'est
inadmissible donc moi ça tenait à
regarder le match
et les mecs vont se voir un peu sur la
vidéo pour voir comment leur attitude
sur le terrain
c'est la première fois de la saison on
prend l'eau on prend l'eau ainsi à
domicile en plus du coup ça a sûrement
un peu déçu
les supporters qui étaient venus assez
nombreux ce soir donc on va on
retravaille on va se remettre en
question et on va en parler ensemble
cyclisme sur piste à présent la
sélection française pour les
championnats du monde d'apeldoorn a été
dévoilée ce mardi 6 février au vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
dans l'équipe masculine les coaches ont
décidé de retenir les têtes d'affiché
comme quentin lafargue benjamin thomas
le jeune sébastien vigier 20 ans et
l'expérimenté françois pervis ils
montent à remporter sept titres de
champion du monde à 33 ans
on retrouve également le plaisir aux
amis qu'elle a d'almeida qui réintègre
l'équipe de france après avoir été
écarté pendant un an et demi suite aux
jo de 2016
chez les filles le staff a notamment
retenu laurie berton médaille d'argent
aux championnats du monde 2007 toujours
à chez les féminines l'une des plus
grandes promesses du cyclisme sur piste
français et également dans l'équipe
matile de gros à 18 ans trois fois
championne du monde junior et dans la
liste moins de quatre mois après sa
blessure à l'épaule en coupe du monde et
une opération nous avons pu la
rencontrer au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines pour avoir sa
réaction juste après cette annonce la
sélection pour les championnats du monde
vient tout juste de tomber je suis à
côté de mathilde de gros qui a été
sélectionné en sprint mathilde de gros
est ce que c'est une surprise d'être
sélectionnés pour ces championnats du
monde aux pays-bas
c'est on va dire je suis assez je suis
très contente parce que c'était pas très
près 20 c'est pas prévu à la base
ou alors serez été c'était difficile
mais bon je suis vraiment contente et
comme j'ai hâte de pouvoir les faire
vous avez été blessé du coup au mois de
novembre à l'épaule est-ce que la
blessure est cicatrisée
elle est pas tout à fait cicatrisées je
suis en train lendemain ça va faire
trois mois que je serais tombé dans la
phase ii entre trois et six mois faut
faire attention parce que on se sent
bien que ça commence à revenir à
redevenir solide mais il faut faire
attention notamment mais en tout cas on
1 quand même une épaule qui redevient de
plus en plus forte donc il faut attendre
six mois je crois pour avoir la
plénitude de ses moyens après une
blessure comme celle là mais au bout de
six mois après on aura une épaule tout à
fait normal donc avant six mois il faut
quand même faire attention mais
voilà quand même rester sur ses gardes
continuer les soins mais on a une épaule
quasi normal on y va dans quel état
d'esprit quand on n'est pas à 100% pour
des championnats du monde
alors même si voilà j'ai un problème d
paul je vais tout faire pour
en tout cas donné mon 100 pour cent à
moi je suis une compétitrice donc voilà
je vais essayer d'aller le plus loin
possible
après je vais faire avec mes moyens mais
le plus important là pour moi sur ce
championnat ça va être de retrouver du
plaisir parce que ce sera ma première
course depuis ma chute
donc voilà l'objectif c'est de reprendre
du plaisir et j'espère vraiment être
assez forte pour aller le plus loin
possible dans la compétition il ya quand
même un objectif de médailles avant la
chute oui mais
là vraiment depuis ma chute depuis je
suis cité je me dis que voilà je prend
les matches un par un et je vais avancer
dans la compétition comme ça et voilà
déjà je vais voir le 200 m où est ce que
je me situe par rapport aux autres parce
que ben on sait que les autres filles en
championnat du monde tout le monde se
prépare à fond et va être au top de sa
forme
- ça va être différent mais je vais tout
faire pour faire partie des meilleurs
vous avez été trois fois champion du
monde chez les juniors là c'est chez les
élites ces championnats du monde
est ce qu'il ya une grosse différence ou
finalement la différence est minime
entre les deux épreuves
il ya une énorme différence a rien à
voir rien à voir mais vraiment rien à
voir c'est un palier et normes ce et
voilà les meilleurs du monde les
championnes olympiques là c'est vraiment
le plus haut niveau qu'on peut atteindre
et je suis contente d'y participer parce
que voilà j'ai pu faire notamment chanté
à d'europe en septembre avant ma chute
là on passe encore un cran notamment et
dernière quand j'ai fait à hong kong
j'ai fait 5e j'espère est enfin là
j'espère cette année faire mieux après
on va voir en fonction de l'épaule mais
c'est vrai que le niveau ça a rien à
voir entre cet été cet hiver c'est
quelque chose de complètement différent
un podium ce sera déjà une réussite pour
vous ce sera quelque chose
d'extraordinaire à ce moment là parce
que ouais ça franchement c'est la
surprise ah ouais c'est vraiment une
très grosse surprise si je suis sur le
podium après on sait jamais hein qui
sert donc il ya plusieurs paramètres
aussi qui vous entourent il ya cette
blessure à l'épaule il ya également
cette sphère médiatique qui grossit
autour de vous vous êtes jeune vous avez
à 18 ans et vous allez au championnat du
monde et où vous annonce comme la future
pépite du cyclisme français
est ce qu'il n'ya pas trop de pression
qui vous entourent
malheureusement je suis très bien
entouré de par ma famille mon entraîneur
et
c'est vrai que pour l'instant je réalise
pas trop où il ya des médias une
pression médiatique certes mais pour moi
je suis une fille normale est en tout
cas mon but c'est de pédaler plus vite
possible d'être la meilleure du monde et
voilà ces géants tout cas pour l'instant
je ne sens pas trop faim voilà j'ai vite
je préfère rester dans ma bulle
quand tu as des médias qui font répond
il n'y a pas de problème et après c'est
vrai je reste vraiment concentré sur moi
et enfin voila mon vélo ma santé je
pense que c'est que comme ça que je
pouvoir réussir à être la meilleure du
monde
merci beaucoup mathilde de gros les
championnats du monde c'est aux pays bas
du 28 février au 4 mars
on reste au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines après quatre
manches qualificatives les finales de la
coupe d'hiver se sont déroulés ce
week-end sur la piste olympique
sept clubs franciliens et plus d'une
centaine d'athlètes à participer à cette
deuxième édition en montage de à xavier
jaglin de l'engagement les meilleurs
athlètes de sept clubs franciliens sur
la piste les finales de la coupe d'hiver
ont tenu toutes leurs promesses ce
dimanche 11 février au vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
pour cette deuxième édition 110 sportifs
ont été sélectionnés sur quatre épreuves
pour participer au rendez vous sur les
quatre manches
nous avons eu 650 participants
donc la deuxième édition a été une
réussite ça monte en puissance
tous les coureurs manifestent beaucoup
d'intérêt à venir à saint quentin
au programme des épreuves d'omnium et de
vitesse de la catégorie minimes à
seniors objectif de cette journée
proposé aux coureurs un entraînement
grandeur nature pour les faire
progresser
le fait d'avoir à faire des épreuves
c'est vrai que on gagne en expérience
plus on est bien encadré dans le club il
ya de bons conseils donc c'est surtout
tactiquement que j'ai bien progressé
la dernière compétition j'ai fait je
suis tombé du coup il assure s'être
lassé de bas me rassurer en compétition
donc plus puisse me coller aux autres
sans avoir peur le rendez vous a
également pour objectif de faire
découvrir la piste olympique du vélotour
nationale et ses virages de huit mètres
au coureur les images sont assez
impressionnants au début parce que c'est
vraiment foutu
après
les lignes droites c'est moins
impressionnant mais il ya beaucoup de
sensations quand nous longeons les
mirages
c'est une super piste il faut bosser dur
est l'un des plus beaux au vélodrome au
monde donc on a vraiment de la chance de
faire nos compétitions sur une telle
piste pareil une troisième édition
devrait être programmée l'année
prochaine elle pourrait cette fois-ci
inclure des coureurs venus de toute
l'europe
il était l'invité de cette coupe d'hiver
ce dimanche on le pense et à la retraite
mais il nous a une nouvelle fois surpris
robert marchand qui a fêté ses 106 ans
en novembre dernier était de retour sur
la piste du vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines un peu plus
d'un an après son record de l'heure il a
réalisé à 16 tours de piste pour une
distance totale de 4000 mètres alors
qu'il ne devait réaliser que 10 tours
initialement on écoute la réaction du
centenaire a sorti de ce nouvel exploit
j'aurais été capable de vous êtes
content de revenir ici mais entendu je
vois incroyable c'est un pont royal
j'ai déjà vu j'avais peur
[Musique]
j'ai été mieux que robert marchand
envisage même de remonter sur son vélo
pour participer à des compétitions si
ses médecins lui accorde une
autorisation amoa d'athlétisme à présent
au comme robert marchand il adore les
exploits sa spécialité défier la gravité
selon abdoulaye diarra ce sportif de
montigny le bretonneux a réalisé la
meilleure performance française de
l'année en saut en hauteur avec 2 m 17
nous avons la chance de le recevoir sur
ce plateau avec son entraîneur éric
nogaro qui nous vient tout droit de le à
saint quentin en yvelines
bonsoir à tous les deux alors je le
disais précédemment vous avez réalisé
une super performance au meeting
national
vous attendiez une performance de ce
type de scène jimmy hayes janvier de
toute façon ça fait un certain temps
qu'on se prépare de cette façon pourrait
faire ce genre de performance maintenant
voilà j'ai fait de mettre 17 s'est passé
pas ridicule je pense que je capable de
faire mieux
on va continuer à s'entraîner pour
l'apprécier d'aller encore plus haut de
toute façon coach vous a surpris
sur ce meeting non c est ce qu il a
quand même eu longévité et puis une
régularité sur les hauteurs donc vu son
âge c'est très très bien
maintenant il est capable de sortir des
très beaux concours dans les moments
importants et ça c'est quelque chose de
très intéressant travail et comment vous
sentez vous sur ce début d'année 2010 et
bah je me sens plutôt bien bon là j'ai
une petite gêne au niveau du genou mais
je me sens plutôt bien je me prends pas
trop la tête je m'entraîne comme je peux
après voilà je me rends dans une autre
phase de ma vie où je viens d'avoir un
enfant il a neuf mois donc voilà je dois
un peu moins voilà donc le bébé malade
on s'entraîne pas voilà je me prends pas
la tête je me fais plaisir à
l'entraînement je le fais plaisir en
compétition et si l'on aime faire
plaisir de cette façon je suis limite en
bas tableau loisirs coach comment on
fait pour gérer justement à la tête qui
a une double vie on peut le dire c'est
compliqué c'est de dire qu'il faut gérer
les temps de repos les temps de travail
la journée qu'il a fait avant donc voilà
puis on a en étant bon j au programme
sur une semaine un peu tous ces temps-là
de travail entre la technique la
musculation et puis le renforcement donc
on essaye de gérer ça harmonieusement
sur six mois sept mois pour arriver sur
au bon moment le jour j vous êtes un
showman hors vous étiez un cheval je
vais à quelques mois c'est toujours un
cheval malgré l'arrivée d'autres enfants
je suis toujours de toute façon ça c'est
dans mon sang c'est comme ça et puis ça
me permet aussi de ne pas stresser sur
les compétitions
j'aime bien faire le clown mai
voilà j'ai toujours un objectif en vue
toute façon c'est de gagner mais j'ai
besoin de faire le spectacle aussi et
c'est comme ça qu'on me connaît en
france de toute façon je suis je suis un
showman c'est une source de motivation
à défaut en compétition ça peut être un
défaut après il faut savoir le gérer il
est vrai qu'étant plus jeune je n'ai
partie un petit peu trop aux
compétitions à faire le clown et
compagnie là maintenant j'arrive à mieux
gérer
j'arrive mieux à gérer ça me permet
voilà a vraiment pas de ne pas me mettre
la pression qu'on arrive en compétition
en étant relâché pendant que tous les
autres sont en train de stresser il faut
le gérer abdoulaye en compétition phare
i call of duke il est bien un concours
qu'il est à la fête se dire qu'il a
envie de sauter ce jour-là on le voit
sirkis il est bien il en est il fera une
performance le jour où il est plus lent
cette optique de prendre plaisir de la
faire le show on sent qu est qu un petit
quelque chose et donc là il faut le
rebooster un petit peu mais tant qu'à y
c'est pourquoi il y là après il est
capable de faire des miracles vont
porter les couleurs du mali depuis à
2013 pourquoi avoir choisi le mali ah ça
c'est une bonne question de la possible
anciennement j'étais en équipe de france
je fais plusieurs plusieurs sélections
en équipe de france après
comment dire bon je suis profondément
français je finis en france j'ai une
culture française maintenant voilà le
mali c'est le pays de mes parents je me
suis dit bon bah pour enfin les moyens
non sollicitée de niveau mais pourquoi
pas tenter l aventure
après je vais pas rentrer dans les
détails j'ai d'autres complications avec
l'équipe du mali veut pas rentrer dans
les détails maintenant voilà c'était
juste un choix
voilà je n'avais rien contre la france
j'ai jamais eu de 1er que la france ni
quoi que ce soit mais c'était juste
voilà je voulais voir ce qui se faisait
sur un autre continent
vous avez 29 ans vous avez qu'à titre de
champion de france en saut en hauteur
votre carrière elle est plus derrière
vous ou devant vous à 29 ans elle est
plus derrière moi maintenant et c'est
notre carrière qui commence comme le dit
c'est une carrière de papa là qui comme
en france mais ma carrière sportive
assez clair qu'elle est belle et plus
derrière moi maintenant 29 ans voilà il
me reste peut-être quatre ans peut-être
quatre ans a tout pété mais après enfin
voila je pense que mon corps me dire
stop sinon je continuerai chez les
vétérans est-ce qu'il peut encore
s'améliorer techniquement oui cirque en
fait sur les qualités physiques ça
devient difficile avec l'âge mais par
contre il a
un souper spécial spectaculaire puisque
tout le monde connait adoulaye pour un
son sourd ciseaux donc c'est ce qui a
fait connaître à dubaï maintenant
techniquement il peut encore progresser
ce qui fait qu'il arrive à compenser un
peu ce manque de physique et à son âge
la nar question quels sont vos prochains
objectifs
c'est une compétition carrie projet les
championnats de france la semaine
prochaine déjà donc l'objectif c'est de
gagner comme d'habitude fois comme
d'habitude voilà j'ai quand j'arrivais
en compétition c'est pas pour pour
regarder les autres monsieur moix
congédiant c'est pour gagner donc
l'objectif c'est de gagner et de se
faire plaisir
après la performance on verra si si
j'irai plus ici je vais plus haut mais
bon de toute façon
voilà j'ai pas de limites on va dire
mais limité entre la terre et le ciel
c'est tout on vous le souhaite en tout
cas merci à tous les deux dépassé ce bon
courage pour les championnats de france
on continuera à vous suivre dans cette
émission dans les prochains 7,8 sport je
vous propose maintenant de partir du
côté du golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines coup de
projecteur aujourd'hui sur mathilde de
classe cette jeune athlète de 17 ans est
en sport études depuis à cinq ans grâce
à la fédération française de golf
un programme qui lui permet d'allier
deux objectifs personnels obtenir son
bac et devenir joueuse professionnelle
en s'entraînant dans les conditions
idéales pour le haut niveau des images
de patrick jacques de dixmude le monde a
découvert son visage aux côtés du
golfeur thomas ce viol en octobre
dernier pour la journée ryder cup au
golf national va-t-il de classe 17 ans
fait partie des golfeuses françaises les
plus doués de sa génération
l'envers du décor et plus studieux la
jeune lilloise intégrer une section
sport étude de la fédération française
depuis cinq ans au premier truc à faire
on vérifie l'élément commun donc entre
eux cet occident et son réducteur
associer ses caractéristiques de quoi
dans une solution un jeu règne dans
cette classe aménagée au golf national
mathilde suit des cours petit groupe de
quatre élèves
la sportive passe en moyenne cinq heures
par jour loin des greens pour préparer
son bac scientifique
j'ai la partie des géants statut de
sportive au niveau de la
l'éducation nationale de passer mon bac
en deux ans donc j'ai séparer les
matières et donc ça me facilite la tâche
un peu ça ne donne plus de temps pour
faire les deux pour gérer les deux une
fois les cours terminés direction les
terrains de golf la pièce qui a commencé
ce sport à 5 ans à villennes-sur-seine
tape la balle une vingtaine d'heures
chaque semaine nos gars étaient même si
j'ai un bac et faut que je fasse des
études après mais c'est d'abord le golfe
et ouais je préfère passer du temps à
m'entraîner le soir soit les sessions
incluse dans le programme sport études
sont encadrés par un coach national
elles doivent lui permet d'accéder aux
gros tournois mondiaux pour atteindre le
haut niveau elles sont obligées
d'augmenter la quantité de
l'entraînement et
c'est pour ça que cette structure a été
créée un entraînement intensif sur le
plan golfique dans tous les facteurs de
performance ont à la fois sur la partie
technique sur la dimension physique
donc tout est organisé autour de ça pour
mettre là je la joue dans l'est dans les
meilleures conditions
voilà plus devant toi à travers
je pense que ça aide beaucoup les filles
qui sont pas une structure comme nous je
sais qu'elles ont beaucoup de mal
surtout en terminale mais qui a le bac
c'est vraiment dur de concilier les deux
et nous bat wav aiff bien grâce à sa
savane eu plus de bars une idée pour
m'entraîner elle progressait à mathilde
envisage maintenant de partir aux usa
dans une faculté pour continuer à jouer
sur les deux tableaux le golf et les
études avec un objectif en tête
participer aux jo de 2024 qui seront
organisés à saint quentin en yvelines
[Musique]
ce sera une première dans les yvelines
des matchs de floorball un sport dérivé
du hockey sur glace sont programmées ce
samedi ce dimanche à buc au gymnase du
prés saint jean
ces rencontres compteront pour le
championnat de france de d3 pour nous
parler à de ce rendez-vous nous recevons
sur ce plateau le président du club des
jets de but que mathieu vilar et
sébastien le faucheur entraîneur et
nathalie à bélier la joueuse bonsoir
alors je lui disais précédemment ce sera
une grande première dans les yvelines
président exactement
donc ça fait trois ans que le club
existe à buc dans les yvelines c'est
notre donc troisième saison et pour
cette première saison enfin pour cette
troisième saison nous avons démarré une
équipe en championnat de france d3 et
pour la première fois nous allons
accueillir un tour du championnat de
france de la poule nord de troisième
division donc nous allons accueillir des
équipes comme tour montbazon une oie
paris université club et une entente
entre le mans et bordeaux
il y aura trois matchs par jour trois
matches par journée et pour nous donc un
match par journée pour l'ensemble de
l'organisation et pour les jets c'est un
match le samedi un match le dimanche
et si on les gagne ce soir week-end
dommage sur le week-end et c'est le
dernier match de la saison régulière
avec
l'optique en fait de poursuivre les
aventures et de rentrer en play-offs
nathalie ce type d'événement c'est
important pour le club de créer on va
dire l'événement autour autour d'une
compétition pour attirer encore plus de
licenciés évidemment en plus c'est
vraiment la première fois
qu'on reçoit chez nous donc déjà on est
content tout le monde peut participer à
ce que certains peuvent pas se déplacer
quand c'est ailleurs et puis on peut
faire parler de nous un peu plus en tout
cas c'est ce qu'on espère ça permet
également de promouvoir ce sport qui
n'est pas forcément très médiatisé en
france et dans les yvelines
exactement aujourd'hui en france on a
1000 1500 licenciés
donc on est un sport relativement
mineures on est une trentaine
quarantaine de clubs en france donc
c'est l'occasion pour nous de faire
parler du floorball dans les yvelines on
est le seul club dans les yvelines on
espère et comment l'expliquez vous je
pense que ça progresse d'année en année
il ya de nouveaux clubs qui est qui se
créent pour l'instant il n'est peut-être
pas encore de gens qui ont suffisamment
connu le floorball pour initier le
mouvement dans les yvelines mais ça va
venir j'en suis certain et quels sont
vos objectifs sur le terrain ça sera de
remporter les deux matches l'objectif
c'est effectivement remporté les deux
matches on est sur une bonne dynamique
avec plus tôt aujourd'hui des résultats
positifs de défaite
six victoires donc si on peut engranger
encore deux victoires on pourra
peut-être se donner rendez vous pour
parler on est deuxième de notre poule il
faut être dans les deux premiers de
détroit et il faut être dans les deux
premiers pour accéder aux play-offs et
on va jouer contre notre concurrent
direct le dimanche
donc voilà ça sera un match très
important pour nous à gagner pour être
pour continuer l'aventuré
nathalie vous avez préparé ce match de
la meilleure des manières daniel cotton
bien sûr je suis allé courir presque
tous les jours à travailler le cardio
la technique tombe on peut venir
président pour encourager tout le monde
il ya des gradins il y aura une buvette
l'entrée est gratuite et on attend un
maximum de supporters pour nous
encourager
durant le week-end comme supporters
maximum tant qu'on veut je pense que des
centaines en croissance merci à tous les
trois lettres passé sur ce plateau et
bon courage pour ces deux matches qui
sera organisée à ce week-end et on le
souhaite de remporter vos deux matches
merci on termine ce magazine par un
rendez-vous la coupe de france de danses
latines et standards est programmée ce
samedi 17 février au gymnase mont boron
de versailles en événement organisé en
partenariat avec la fédération française
de danse les éliminatoires débutent à
partir de 10 heures et les finales
commenceront à 20 heures plus d'une
cinquantaine de sportifs est attendue
pour cet événement c'est la fin de ce
statut de sport merci de l'avoir suivi
très belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]